balma la vente à porter la couronne de
miss france pendant un an et cette fois
ça va être à ton tour de remettre des
couronnes je vais proposer à chaque fois
deux fois et tu devrais le dire
lequel selon toi mérite la couronne
d'accord on commence avec la couronne de
mister relou selon toi qui mérite le
plus cette couronne entre mathieu et
laurent ruquier alors je vais revoir les
deux classes regarde par exemple
matthieu delormeau et l'on regarde et
matthieu delormeau oui moi je suis
choquée parce qu'effectivement d'abord
ne cherche qu'à faire que du buzz je
suis choqué quand elle dit entre les
mots comme se branler à l'antenne et
tout ça comme elle l'a fait dans des
tweets elle était élue pour être belle
elle n'est pas marianne ne
représenteraient d'autres jeux des
nations lui s'est pas terminée ce qu'on
lui demande c'est prendre sa 508 de
faire la quinzaine du reblochon des jo
2010 mais je trouve qu'elle ne cherche
qu'à faire du buzz pour exister derrière
et devenir chroniqueuse et où je sais
pas ou alors vous serez vous dire un
truc vous avez pris 20 piges au monde
alors elle est loin derrière les autres
belles balades ou alors est-ce que c'est
matthieu delormeau bicester au loup ou
laurent ruquier qui dit qu'il faut
boycotter miss france regarde lance un
appel boycottons cette année l'élection
de miss france en plus c'est sur tf1
c'est très bien mais y en a plein les
journaux on n'en peut plus de l'élection
miss france c'est ringard faut être
logique si on veut être ministre
on doit pas écouter aujourd'hui le
concours des miss france ce sera déjà un
bon début
oui alors c'est pas ringard élection
miss fait je pense valmalle massé qui
mister relou pour toi matthieu delormeau
ou l'auront ok alors je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de rencontrer mathieu
delormeau cole mais il a l'air plus
grande donc je suppose qu'il est plus
lourd
matthieu delormeau
[Musique]
ça va lui faire plaisir a battu qui sera
avec nous demain on le remettra sa
couronne qui mérite la couronne de la
couronne la couronne de miss rôle ou
est-ce que c'est rachel legrain trapani
où sylvie tellier puisque rachel
legrain-trapani est persuadé que vaille
malama chavez la déteste regarder je
pense en tout cas qu'elle me déteste et
c'est à cause de toi non elle vous
déteste à cause de moi pourquoi mais en
fait il ya c'était le ya deux trois
semaines on était à paris les beaucoup
de miss france était à paris pour
l'association des bonnes fées et donc
camille serme malika ménard mais dit on
se voit ce soir chez vaima la main j
pourquoi il se passe quelque chose
webhelp une soirée atépa invités banon
je suis non les montages un bref du coup
mais j'ai pas été invitée à la soirée
des miss voilà le nom une invitation
officielle
et c'est vrai cette histoire ou pas bah
oui alors
[Applaudissements]
cette émission est dommage
j'adore les ans sauf bah oui là oui je
vois pas là c'est parce que j'ai dis bah
oui j'ai pas invité mais en même temps
quand on se connaît pas plus que ça afin
d'inviter des gens que tu connais pas
chez toi toi bah oui moi ça m'arrive
il ya des gens que je connais et je les
invite tout le temps on doit envoyer
dans les abattoirs au minigolf et donc y
avait une soirée avec toutes les miss
n'ont pas tout non bakou maintenant là
bas on va comme échanger numéro d'on va
se revoir du malheur à toi tu vas finir
dj alors donc s'équipera peu à l'ap le
rôle ou rachel legrain-trapani ou
s'éviter lycée comme argument principal
va pas tu vois là alors il me semble que
sylvie a plus petit que rachel donc je
suppose que la sheller une fois encore
fumant qu'est-ce que vous ayez à
l'oreille donc c'est quoi donc c'est
donc pour toi là le plus rousse et passe
partout mais la question c'est relou
serreslous en verlan ça me tire lourd
oui mais voilà qui mérite la couronne du
truc le plus chiant
pendant votre règne de miss france poser
en maillot de bain ou ne pas pouvoir
dire de gros mots eux aussi tueur alors
on va voir de vidéos pour l'instant
mieux on va le revoir en bail ou y en
avoir une vie des ossis ou voilà tu été
filmées lors de son bizutage me regarde
ta vidéo ont valu
[Applaudissements]
et il ya une autre vidéo sans filtre
lorsque tu es filmé pendant ton bizutage
regarde c'est la premier gage de cette
intégration les réactions la trouille
j'ai tout [ __ ] et laval il adore et
bars bénac individu est unique et des
châteaux alors c'est quoi le plus relou
mais ça fait partie du vocabulaire
chance et pourquoi est ce que c'est
quand ça devrait être considéré comme
quand même ben pour le coup comme je dis
pas comme au sud il a posé en maille à
s'intéresser un peu relou quand même
maintenant mais c'est parce que je dis
pas de l'houmous donc lui dit pas de
gros mots c'est pas souvent sauf quand
je suis vraiment vraiment énervé je dis
fuite cacahuètes tulipes ou twitter avec
2 ou fait saperlipopette a aussi enjoint
ristic
elle est dernière question qui mérite
selon toi la couronne de la personne
avec qui tu pense finir ta vie les
hommes ou les femmes puisque tu as
déclaré si j'ai un copain j'aimerais
passer des moments avec lui mais pas
avoir besoin spécialement de les
dévoiler ou une copine un parce que je
peux aimer les filles aussi
il y en a certaines qui sont pas mal du
tout j'ai dit oui
donc tu sais pas encore tu vas voir
tintin est bien avec qui j'ai pas finir
ma vie avec moi étant donné que je suis
une fille je dirais fille d'accord c'est
vraiment invitée en soirée
[Musique]
je suis
je suis fan elle est exceptionnelle
je le dis madame arthur à une très
longue carrière je te le dis bah tu
verras je me suis jamais trompé un
françois hollande cité mois